The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM GREEN, JR.:
Shall we get started?
Yes.
Apologies for the notes
being posted so late.
I had trouble with the new two
factor authentication system,
which I need to get into
Stellar and put things up there.
My phone wasn't working so I
had to find my iPad someplace
and use that to get
credentials to log in.
So if you don't have them
don't worry about it.
The full notes are posted
online, no missing pieces.
So you can utilize
those afterwards
if something is unclear.
All right?
So your quizzes are graded.
The TAs have them.
I think overall, we
were really pleased
with the outcome of this quiz.
It is very conceptual
in nature and we
thought people really
understood a lot of the material
quite well.
And you can see that from
the distribution of scores.
So the mean on the
quiz was about 77,
a standard deviation of 12.
I think everyone did
really quite well.
And on a number of the problems,
perfect solutions were posted.
So I'll take a second here.
If there are any questions
about the material that
was on the quiz,
or the format of it
that you'd like
to have addressed,
I'm happy to answer them.
No?
Does it seem like it
took too much time
to complete all three questions
in the two hours allotted?
Or was it about the right length
of material for the time slot?
So we vetted it
with the two TAs.
And it took each of them less
than an hour to complete it.
So that was a good
sign that we thought
you guys should be able
to get through most
of the material in two hours.
So let's recap.
We're going to move on today
to a topic called differential
algebraic equations.
But before doing that, there
are a couple of concepts
I want to review from
numerical integration,
or actually concepts that
weren't covered when we talked
about numerical
integration on Friday
that I think are important.
And then I want
to review briefly
implicit methods for
ODE-IVPs because those
are going to be important
for differential algebraic
equations.
So for numerical
integration we talked
about quadrature of
various integrals,
how to develop
quadrature formulas.
But there's actually
one type of integral
we didn't talk
about there, which
is sort of improper integrals,
where the limits of integration
are unbounded.
And these come up all the
time in engineering problems.
We'd like to know what
the, say, integrated
response of some function
is over all possible times.
And we may have to
evaluate that numerically.
So how do you do those
sorts of integrals?
And it turns out the strategy
that's most often used
is to divide this domain
up into two pieces.
One piece, which
is proper integral
over a finite domain,
and another piece,
which is an improper integral
over an infinite domain.
This first integral,
you can handle it
with an ODE-IVP method or
some higher order polynomial
interpolation.
But the second one we
have to do differently.
And there are couple
of ways to do this.
One is to transform variables.
So you map this domain
onto a finite domain.
And the other option
is to substitute
an asymptotic approximation.
So we say, when, say,
tau is large, f of tau
has a characteristic
asymptotic approximation.
Maybe it's
exponentially decaying.
And we take the integral of
that asymptotic approximation.
And the more accurate
that approximation
is the better our
approximation for this whole
integral will be.
There's another type of
interval that we have to do,
where the same idea
can be applied.
That's the integral over
integrable singularities.
So here's an example.
So say we want to integrate
the function cosine of tau
over square root of tau from
0 to some finite positive time
point.
As tau goes to 0, cosine
goes to 1 and square root
of tau diverges.
But this integral actually
has a finite value.
This 1 over square
root of tau, that's
an integrable singularity.
So how do you do this?
Well, you want to split the
domain again into two parts.
One part that contains
the integrable singularity
and the other part,
which excludes it.
And in the part that
contains the singularity
we might do an asymptotic
expansion of the function,
and integrate each of those
asymptotically accurate terms
separately.
So the integral of 1
over square root of tau
is going to give us
2 tau 0 to the 1/2.
The integral of
this ratio here is
going to give us minus
1/2 t0 to the 5/2.
And then we have an integral
over a finite domain,
which doesn't include
the singularity.
And the accuracy of this method
can be dictated by two things
now.
One is how accurately
can we do this integral.
And the other is how accurate is
our asymptotic expansion here.
So if we want higher
accuracy we need more terms.
We might need to be
selective about how
we choose the end
point for this domain
in order to minimize the error.
There are lots of
methods to do this.
Sam.
AUDIENCE: Will you
talk a little more
about what typical
integral [INAUDIBLE] is?
WILLIAM GREEN, JR.: Yeah.
So you know these things.
If I try to integrate 1
over x, as x goes to 0
this thing will always diverge.
You know the antiderivative of
1 over x is going to be the log.
And the log diverges.
So power is weaker than 1 over
x, like 1 over x to the 1/2.
Don't diverge like the log.
They actually go
to a finite value.
The log is like the most weakly
singular function there is.
And integrals over weaker
powers of 1 over x actually
don't produce a
singularity anymore.
They're what we call
integrable singularities.
The function itself diverges
but its integral does not.
So you usually have this
asymptotic power law type
behavior.
OK.
So they come up all the time.
We see these things
in places like, say,
squeezing a thin film of
fluid between two plates.
How long does it take for these
two plates to come together?
You might say, well, as the
plates get closer and closer
together the pressure
starts to diverge in the gap
and they'll never come together.
But maybe depending on
the geometry of the plates
there can be a
sort of finite time
at which they'll come together.
Depends on their geometry.
So that's one topic.
I think that's useful
because these things come up
all the time.
And you can't actually handle
those cases with quadrature
by itself.
The function diverges.
There's no polynomial
interpolation
that's suitable to match it.
So the quadrature
can't handle it.
And if you're trying
to integrate over
an infinite domain,
well, good luck.
You're never going to be
able to fit enough points in
to know that you've accurately
integrated out to infinity.
The other thing I
want to recap here,
and this is a problem
for you to try.
So here we have a simple first
order ordinary differential
equation.
We want to use the implicit
Euler method to solve it.
So can you give a
closed form solution
for one step of the
implicit Euler method,
or for n steps of the
implicit Euler method?
What result does that produce?
Can you compute this?
Do you guys talk about backward
Euler methods for for ODE-IVPs?
Backwards difference methods in
general and the backwards Euler
method specifically?
No.
OK.
Well, clearly I
should have been here.
So what's the strategy?
We have to approximate
the derivative.
Yes?
So the approximation for
the derivative we use
is a finite difference
approximation.
So we write dx dt
as x at a point k
plus 1 minus x at the
point k divided by delta t.
Backwards difference.
We evaluate the right-hand
side of the ODE-IVP at k
plus 1, xk plus 1.
And then we solve for xk plus 1.
We just substitute in here.
Backwards difference
approximation
for the differential.
And xk plus 1 for
the right-hand side.
And we find that xk
plus 1 will be 1 over 1
minus delta t times
this lambda times xk.
And if we iterate this from k
equals 0 up to some finite k,
it's like multiplying
by powers of 1 over 1
minus delta t times lambda.
Yes?
Does this makes sense?
So our backwards Euler solution
to this fundamental problem
is going to look like this.
And a lot of times we
ask about the stability
of these sorts of solutions.
So if for example, the
solution to this equation
was supposed to
decay to zero, we
would expect our
numerical method
to also yield results
which decay to zero.
We would call that stable.
So we all know under
what conditions
does xk, for example, go to 0
as I change the product delta
t times lambda.
Lambda could be a real number or
it can be a complex number too.
Doesn't really matter.
So what needs to be true for xk
to the k to 0 as k gets bigger?
Well what needs to be true is
this quantity in parentheses
needs to be smaller
than 1 because I'm
taking lots of
products of things
that are smaller than one.
That will continue to shrink xk
from x 0 until it goes to zero.
If this is smaller than 1,
then this quantity down here
needs to be bigger than
1 in absolute value.
And then I'll get solutions
that slowly decay to zero.
So if I ask, for what values
of delta t times lambda
is the absolute value of
this thing bigger than 1,
and I allow lambda to be a
complex number, for example?
I'll find out that's
true when 1 minus delta t
times the real part
of lambda squared
plus delta t times the
imaginary part of lambda squared
is bigger than 1.
And if I plot the real
part of delta t times
lambda versus the imaginary
part of delta times lambda,
this inequality is
represented by this pink zone
on the outside of the circle.
So any values of
delta t times lambda
that live in this pink area
will give stable integration.
And the solution xk, well, the
k to zero as k goes to infinity.
So it makes sense?
This is a little funny though.
What does the solution
to this equation
do when lambda is bigger than 1?
When it's bigger
than 0, excuse me.
When lambda is
bigger than 0, what
does the solution
to this ODE-IVP do?
Does it decay?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR.: It blows up.
It grows exponentially.
But the numerical
method here, when
I have lambda is
bigger than zero,
can be stable and produce
decaying solutions.
So this is sort of peculiar.
So we're often concerned
when we solve ODE-IVPs
and we try to use these
sorts of backwards difference
methods, these implicit
methods, to solve them.
We're often concerned
with getting stability.
We want to get
solutions that decay
when they're supposed to decay.
Sometimes we get
solutions that decay even
when the solution is
supposed to blow up.
So that's sort of funny.
So the exact solution
should look like this.
But there are going to
be circumstances where
lambda is bigger than zero.
In fact, lambda is bigger than--
lambda delta t is bigger
than 2 along the real axis,
where the solution will actually
blow up rather than decay away.
So stability and
accuracy don't always
correlate with each other.
We really have to understand
the underlying dynamics
of the problem we're
trying to solve
before we choose a numerical
method to apply to it.
And this is going to be true
of differential algebraic
equations as well.
Are there any
questions about this?
There's a discussion of these
things in your textbook,
these sorts of stability
regions associated
with different backwards
difference methods.
The implicit Euler method is one
backwards difference formula.
It's the simplest one.
It's the least accurate
one that you can derive
but it's an easy one to use.
But now we want to move on to
a different sort of problem.
And it's one that we come across
in engineering all the time.
These problems are
called differential
algebraic equations.
And they're problems of the
sort a function of some state
variables, and the derivatives
of those state variables
and time is equal to zero.
And there are some
initial conditions.
The state variables at that
time 0 is equal to some x0.
So this is a vector
valued function
of a vector valued state
and it's time derivatives.
And we want to understand
the dynamics of this system.
How does x vary
with time in a way
that's consistent with
this governing equation?
Usually we call these
well-posed problems
when the dimension of the
state variable and the function
are the same.
They both live in
the vector space rn.
So we have n different states.
I have n different functions
that I have to satisfy.
And I want to understand
how x varies with time.
Here's an example.
A stirred tank.
I call this stirred
tank, example one.
So into the stirred tank comes
some concentration of solute.
Out of the stirred tank comes
some different concentration
of the same solute.
And we want to model the
dynamics as a function of time.
So we know that a
material balance
of the solute on the stirred
tank, if it's well mixed,
will tell us that d c2 dt is
related to the volumetric flow
rate into the tank divided
by the volume of the tank
multiplied by the difference
between c1 and c2,
the amount carried in and the
amount carried out of the tank.
And let's put a
constraint in here too.
Let's suppose we're trying to
control this tank in some way.
So we say that c1
of time has got
to be equal to some
control signal, gamma of t.
And then we want to understand
the dynamics of this system.
At time 0, c2 is some c0,
the initial concentration
of the tank.
And c1 is whatever the initial
value of this control signal
is.
And the solution is
c1 equals gamma of t.
And c2 is, well, the
initial concentration's
got to decay out exponentially.
And then I've got to
integrate over how
the input is changing in time.
Those also produce
exponential decay.
So if the input is a
little delta function spike
then I'll get an exponential
decay leaving the tank.
If the input is changing
dynamically in time,
I need this convolution of
the input with this integral.
So you just to
solve this system,
this ordinary
differential equation
by substituting c1 in there.
But this system of
equations here is not just
a differential equation.
It's a differential equation
and an algebraic equation.
There's something
peculiar about that that's
different than just
solving systems
of ordinary
differential equations.
Oftentimes in models,
we write down all
the governing equations
associated with the model.
Some of them may be
differential, some of them
may be algebraic.
There are times when we
can look at those equations
and see clever substitutions
that we can make.
But if you have a hundred
equations, or a thousand
equations, or a
million equations,
there's no way to
do that reliably.
We just kind of wind up with a
system of ordinary differential
equations and algebraic
equations mixed together.
And we have to solve
these reliably.
Here's another example.
Oh, excuse me.
So let me write
this in this form.
So we said there should
be a vector valued
function of the states and
the derivatives of the states.
The states are the
concentration c1 and c2.
And the derivative
here is dc 2 dt.
So here's my vector
valued function.
The first element is
this, and it's equal to 0.
The second element is
Here's my initial
condition over the states.
So I can just transform
that list of equations
to the sort of canonical
form for a differential
algebraic equation.
Here's a separate example.
Suppose instead, I'm
trying to either control
or make a measurement of the
outlet concentrations c2.
And we call that gamma of t.
And I want to know now
what is c2 and what is c1?
So I've got to solve this system
of equations for c2 and c1.
The solution for c2 is easy.
I know that.
c2 is gamma, by definition.
I got to substitute this
into the first equation
and solve for c1.
And I see, c1 is gamma
plus v over q gamma dot.
And I have to have initial
conditions to go along
with this.
There's something funny here.
We can see the initial condition
for c2 has to be gamma 0.
The initial condition for c1,
what does that have to be?
Well, it needs to be consistent
with the solution here.
There were no free
variables when
I solved this equation for c1.
It isn't like solving a
differential equation,
having a free
coefficient to specify.
So it better be the
case that this c0 here
is the same as gamma 0
plus v over q gamma dot 0.
Somehow I have to know this
input signal to prescribe
the initial conditions for c1.
So that's peculiar and
different from just ODE-IVPs.
You see this picture?
You see how this goes together?
The solution is funny too.
Suppose we are trying to
use this system of equations
to do the following.
We are trying to measure c2
and use the measurement of c2
to predict c1.
So gamma is the
measurement, and we're
trying to solve this system
of differential algebraic
equations to predict what c1 is.
All measurements
incur numerical error.
So even though our signal
for gamma that we measure
may be continuous, it's
bouncing around wildly.
It's not a constant signal.
It's going to move
around a great deal.
And c1, our predicted
value for c1,
depends on the
derivatives of gamma,
which means c1 is going to be
incredibly sensitive to how
that measurement is made.
So it's peculiar.
It means that there's going
to be a lot of problems
with stably solving these
equations because the solutions
can admit cases where they're
not integrals of the input
but they're actually related
to derivatives of the input.
Look at the solution
back here again.
Oop, sorry.
The solution here was related
to an integral of the input.
Suppose I was making
a measurement of c1
in trying to predict c2 instead?
My prediction for c2 would
be related to the integral
of that measured signal.
And we know integrals
smooth signals out.
So it's not going to be so
sensitive to the measurement.
So one way of doing this
seems really sensible.
And the other way of doing
it seems a little bizarre.
Well, we can construct these
equations however we want.
So there's something about
how we formulate models
that are going to make
them either easily
solvable, as DAEs, or
quite difficult to solve.
So these pop up all the time
in engineering problems.
They pop up in
dynamic simulations,
where we have some sort
of underlying conservation
principle, or constraints,
or equilibria.
So if we have to
conserve something,
like total energy, total mass,
total momentum, total particle
number, total atomic
species, total charge,
there will always be an
algebraic constraint that
tells us the total
mass has to stay this,
or the total number of atoms of
a certain type has to say this.
Yeah, Ian.
AUDIENCE: Just to be clear, were
you saying, on the stirred tank
example, that those
were the same problem
with different
solution approaches?
WILLIAM GREEN, JR.:
So good question.
Let me go back.
So they are fundamentally
different problems.
So in one case I specified the
value of c2 to be this gamma.
I tried to make a measurement
of c2 and then predict c1.
In the other case,
I specified c1.
I tried to measure
c1 and predict c2.
So one case I measured
the input and tried
to predict the
output to the tank.
And in the other case
I measured the output
and tried to use it
to predict the input.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So physically
the same system
with a choice by the operator.
WILLIAM GREEN, JR.: Yes.
That's right.
So I formulated the
model differently.
The same underlying
system but I formulated
the model differently.
And it led to completely
different behavior
in the underlying solution
to the differential algebraic
equations.
So you've already
solved problems
that involve conservation.
You've done things like
ODE-IVPs on batch reactors,
where the total amount of
material in the reactor
had to remain constant.
Instead, you probably
solved for the dynamics
of each of the components
undergoing the reaction.
You might have checked to
see if at each point in time
the total mass in the
reactor stayed the same.
Because you solved all these
differential equations,
they were interconnected
with each other
but they all incurred
some numerical error.
It's possible that
numerical error
accrues in a way that
actually has you losing mass
from your system.
So there may be benefits
to actually trying
to solve these sorts
of systems of equations
with, say, one less
differential equation
for one of the components and
instead an algebraic constraint
governing the total mass
or total number of moles
in the system.
So these pop up all the time.
You see them in models
of reaction networks,
where we try to use a pseudo
steady state approximation.
We say some reactions go so
fast that they equilibrate.
So they're not governed
by differential equations
but by algebraic
equations for equilibria.
They can pop up in models
of control, where we neglect
the controller dynamics.
So you say I'm going to
try to control this process
and I get to instantaneously
turn on or off this valve
in response to a measurement.
Actually, controllers have
inherent dynamics in them.
But if I don't put
those dynamics in then
I may get an algebraic equation
instead of a differential
equation for how the
control process occurs.
There are different types
of DAEs that we talk about.
So there's one type that's
called semi-explicit DAEs.
And in these types of
differential algebraic
equations we can
write them in the form
M dx dt is equal to f of x
and t, some initial condition.
You say that this
looks like an ODE-IVP.
M is called the mass matrix.
And it may or may not be the
case that M is invertible.
M may or may not be
a full rank matrix.
So let's look at that
stirred tank example one.
This was the underlying
equation, f of x and dx dt
and t.
Can write it in
semi-explicit form.
If c has two components, c1
and c2, then dc 2 dt-- oops,
this is a typo here.
I really apologize.
This should be a 0, and
this element should be a 1.
I'll correct that online.
I apologize for that.
So this should be
this matrix multiplied
with this differential
should give me
dc 2 dt, this term here.
And a 0 for the second equation.
And then I've got q over v
multiplying c1 and minus c2.
So that gives me
the first line here.
I've got minus c1 coming on
the second equation here.
And those balance
with a 0 and a gamma.
So the lower line reads
like this equation here
and the upper line--
fix this typo--
replace 0 with one,
reads like the
upper equation here.
This is the semi-explicit form
of the differential equation.
You can see this mass
matrix is singular and has
a row that's all zeros.
There's no way to
invert this matrix
and convert it into a system
of ODE-IVPs, which you already
know how to solve.
If the mass matrix is full
rank, which can happen,
you can formulate your
model in such a way
that it takes on this
semi-explicit form.
But if the mass matrix is
full rank and invertible,
then you just invert
the mass matrix.
And now you can apply all
your ODE-IVP techniques
to solve this thing.
The mass matrix doesn't
need to be constant.
Could depend on
the concentration.
It can depend on the states
as well in this form.
I just chose an example
where that isn't the case.
But in general, it can
depend on the states.
If it depends on the
states and we invert it,
then we need to be sure
that the mass matrix is
invertible for all values of
the states, which may or may not
be easy to ensure.
So here's what I'd
like you to try to do.
So here's that stirred
tank example two.
The only difference between
this and the previous one
is that c2 now is set equal
to gamma instead of c1.
I want you to try to write
it in semi-explicit form.
A sort of test of understanding.
Can you define the mass matrix?
Can you write out
the right-hand side
of the equation in
semi-explicit form?
Take a second, work
with your neighbor.
See if you can figure
out how to do that.
AUDIENCE: Is this clear?
OK to do this?
WILLIAM GREEN, JR.: You can
look back on the previous slide.
Actually, the semi-exclusive
form is going to be the same.
This is a 0, that's a 1.
The only difference is
going to be c2 is now
balanced with gamma, the input.
So this minus 1 is
got to shift over.
So I switched the
0 for the minus 1,
you got the second,
the semi-explicit form.
There's another way that
these equations can pop up.
So we have this mass matrix.
And it might be
the case that M is
diagonal over many of
the states and then
0 for all the other states.
So we might be able to write
the equation in this form.
This comes up all the time.
So we might be able
to write dx dt is
a function of x, y, and t.
And 0 is equal to another
function of x, y, and t.
And we have some
initial conditions
prescribed for the
x's, of which we're
taking the differential
in one of these equations.
And we've also got to satisfy
those initial conditions
for these variables y associated
with the second nonlinear
equation.
The x's are called the
differential states
because they're involved
in equations where they're
difference with respect to
time, or the differential
with respect to time is taken.
y are called the
algebraic states
because they only appear
as themselves and not
as their time differential
in any of these equations.
So we might want to solve
for both the differential
and the algebraic
states simultaneously.
We have to know these
algebraic states to determine
the differential states.
We have to know the
differential states to determine
the algebraic states.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
WILLIAM GREEN, JR.: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM GREEN,
JR.: That's right.
So here the x that I have
is not all of the states.
It's not all of the unknowns.
It's only the set of
the unknowns of which I
have to take a differential.
That's right, that's right.
So we've sort of tooled
down the kinds of equations
we might want to look at.
We've gone from the generic
differential algebraic equation
to a semi-explicit form to the
splitting, this differential
algebraic splitting.
Many problems can be
formulated in this fashion.
This one's the
easiest one to think
about so that's the
one that we'll discuss
for most of the lecture.
So let's look at some examples.
I think examples are
interesting to think about.
So here's one.
Think about a mass
spring system.
There's an algebraic
equation that
governs a conserved
quantity, the total energy
of this mass spring system.
So the kinetic energy, 1/2 m
times the velocity of the mass
squared.
Plus the energy stored in
the spring, 1/2 kx squared
has got to be equal
to the total energy.
And the total energy
can change in time.
So we have a differential
algebraic equation.
We have a differential
state because we're taking
the time derivative of x.
And we'd like to be
able to determine
x as a function of time.
So f of x, x dot and t.
That's this equation, 1/2
mv squared plus one half kx
squared minus E is equal to 0.
We'd like to solve this
differential algebraic
equation.
It's well-posed.
We have one equation for
one unknown, one state.
The equation has
a solution, which
is a times cosine omega t.
It's not the only
possible solution.
It's a solution
to this equation.
We can substitute that
solution into the equation
and determine, for example
what this oscillation frequency
omega has to be.
It's square root of k over m.
Or what the amplitude has to be.
It's the square
root of E over k.
So you've seen this
from physics before.
We've already
solved differential
algebraic equations.
The thing you saw before
though, was actually
conservation of momentum.
You converted this
entirely to a second order
differential equation
in x and solved it.
But in principle, we could have
tried to find various solutions
to this equation instead.
We would have said, well, we've
observed masses and springs
and we know they
oscillate in time.
So let's propose some
oscillatory solutions
and see what values of
the amplitude and omega we
need to satisfy this equation.
It would have been a
perfectly acceptable way
of solving this problem.
The thing is, this
mass spring problem,
the differential
algebraic equation
contains nonlinearities
with respect to the states.
So it's nonlinear
in the velocity
and it's nonlinear
in the position.
Nonlinear equations in
general are hard to solve.
When you converted that
to a momentum balance
you got linear equations.
You got the second
derivative of position
was equal to stiffness
over mass times position.
It was a linear differential
equation to solve,
which is easy to solve.
So you've got higher
order differentials,
but you linearize the equation
so it made it easier to solve,
in a certain sense.
But we'd like to
sometimes understand what
we can do with these equations.
There are certain
limiting cases where
we can do interesting
things with these equations.
I'm going to show you one now.
So in the case where
the Jacobian of this
function f with respect to
the differential of the state
variable.
So take the derivative
of f with respect
to x dot and hold time
in the state constant.
So this is a matrix,
one that's full rank.
Then the DA be represented
as an equivalent to ODE.
Here's how you can show that.
The total differential of f
is this Jacobian with respect
to x dot times the change x dot
plus the Jacobian with respect
to x times the change in x.
Plus the partial derivative
of f with respect to time,
times the change in time.
And this total differential
has to be equal to 0
because f is equal to 0
for all states in time.
So let's divide by dt.
We'd like to know how
f changes with time.
So total differential
of f with time.
We divide each of these
little differentials by time.
And then we solve for dx dot dt.
That's going to involve
moving this term
to the other side
of the equation
and inverting this Jacobian.
So if I can invert
the Jacobian then
I can convert my DAE system
into a system of ODEs.
This equals 0 shouldn't be here.
I apologize.
That's another typo.
I move this term to the
other side of the equation
to where the 0 is and I solve.
So I went from a first order
equation, a first order
equation in x to a second
order equation in x.
Two differentials of x with
time instead of one differential
of x with time.
But I could convert
it to an equivalent
system of ordinary
differential equations.
Does that make sense?
Do you see how that works?
Any questions?
Let's go back and
look at an example.
The mass spring system.
So here's our ODE that
we're trying to solve.
I'm sorry, our DAE that
Can you convert this to
an equivalent ordinary
differential equation using
the approach I just described?
Think you guys can
figure that out?
Try it.
You can work together.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
WILLIAM GREEN, JR.:
Guys are either tired
or friendships
have been destroyed
over the mid-term season.
Maybe both.
So let's compute the
things we need to know.
We needed to know the partials
of this f with respect
to the states and
with respect to time.
So partial f respect to x dot,
holding all the other variables
constant, is mx dot.
Partial f with
respect to x is kx.
respect to t is t.
And I told you
before that you could
write this says dx
dot dt is equal to df
dx dot inverse multiplied by--
is equal to minus df dx dot
inverse multiplied by df dx.
This was on the previous
slide, which just gives you
conservation of momentum.
This gives you the acceleration
is equal to the force minus kx
divided by the mass m.
So we can solve either,
the DAE or the ODE.
Here's a more
complicated example,
but it works, well,
it's more complicated.
So a lot of times we do
molecular dynamics simulations.
We try to model
molecules moving around.
There we also want
to conserve energy.
There's usually a conserved
quantity, something
we're trying to hold constant.
So suppose we try to do that.
The total energy in this
system of molecules,
maybe it's 1/2 mass times
the velocity squared.
Now x is the position
of all these molecules.
Ad x dot is the velocity
of all these molecules
plus the potential energy,
which is a function of f,
a function of their positions.
So the DAE representing
this constraint is this.
It's the same as
for the mass spring
system, where we've replaced
the potential energy
with a generic one.
This actually isn't
a well-posed DEA.
We have one equation
for, let's see,
if we have n molecules in
here we have three n states.
We can move around
in three dimensions.
So this is a really
ill-posed equation.
If we try to apply the same
procedure, then we say,
well, this quantity still
should be conserved.
Over time it needs
to be equal to zero.
Then we can try to compute
all these differentials.
But we'll find out that
partial f, partial x dot,
the Jacobian of f
with respect to x dot,
that's just the momentum.
That's not a matrix.
That's not invertible.
So we can't convert
this equation
to an equivalent system
of ordinary differential
equations.
So it's just
something pathological
for a one-dimensional system.
Instead, what we find is
zero is equal to the velocity
dotted with the mass times the
acceleration plus the gradient
in the potential.
So minus the forces
acting on the molecules.
We know that if we
were to integrate
the equations of motion
for the molecules exactly,
the momentum balances for
those molecules exactly,
then this term here would
always be equal to zero.
And we'd satisfy
conservation of energy.
Of course, all solutions of
ordinary differential equations
require approximations.
So as you move the
molecules around,
their velocities
and positions will
tend to drift away
from the solution
where this is exactly in
balance and equal to zero.
If you desire to do that in the
molecular dynamic simulation
then you better
have a method that
somehow respects this
geometric property instead.
That the velocities
are orthogonal to m
x dot plus grad v.
And there is a set of
ODE-IVP methods that do that.
They're called
symplectic integrators.
And they integrate the
equations of motion
while exerting some control over
the error in the total energy.
So if you were just
the take a ODE45
and try to solve this
system of equations,
over long times you would find
that the energy drifts away
from the place where it started.
Even though your positions
are being integrated
with reasonable
accuracy, over time
the energy will drift away
from where you started.
The system will heat up
effectively or cool down.
That's undesirable if you're
trying to do modeling.
So instead, one uses the
symplectic integrators,
which are designed to control
the error and the energy
in addition to integrate
the equations of motion.
So you can look those
up and read about them.
I think they're
quite interesting.
If you're going to
do molecular modeling
you'd like to understand
better how they work.
But actually,
conservation of energy
here doesn't give
us a well-posed DAE.
We actually need the
momentum equations
to formulate or to determine the
trajectories of the molecules.
Let's talk about their
numerical simulation.
So let's think about
these semi-explicit DAEs,
the ones that can be
split between differential
and algebraic states.
It's kind of useful to look
at this problem in particular.
And you might say, well, let's
do the simplest possible thing.
Let's do the forward
Euler approximation.
So let's take our derivative
here and represent it
as the state evaluated at x plus
delta t minus the state at t
divided by delta t.
Let's make the right-hand
side of our equation
be evaluated at time t.
And let's try to step in
time, do time marching forward
to determine the
trajectory of x and t.
How do the states change?
We see the first
equation is an easy one
to solve because presumably
I know x of t and y of t.
Well, do I know y of t?
y of t has to satisfy
this second equation.
So first, if I know x of t I
need to solve this nonlinear
equation determine y of t.
Then I know x of
t and y of t and I
can step forward in time to
determine x of t plus delta t.
So every iteration here with the
simplest possible approximation
for the differential
requires solution of a system
of nonlinear equations.
We already saw before that a
forward Euler approximation
is not a great one to apply
to solutions of IDE-IVPs
because it has very limited
stability properties.
You need small
time steps in order
to stably integrate in time.
So even though
this seemed like it
was easy to get a solution
for the differential equation,
we've always got to satisfy
this nonlinear equation here.
So inherently, simulation
of DAEs are implicit.
They require solution
of nonlinear equations
in order to advance in time.
There's actually no point in
using this weakly stable method
for any very small time steps.
It makes more sense to choose
a naturally implicit method
for the differential equation,
where I can take big time steps
and still have reasonable
stability of the integration.
Does that make sense?
Consider now the
fully implicit DAE.
So f of x, x dot,
and t is equal to 0
and have some set of
initial conditions. x of 0
is equal to x 0.
Here there is no way in
general to avoid solving
systems of nonlinear equations.
And so one substitutes
often backwards
difference
approximations for x dot.
And then you solve for
the next point in time.
So here's an example
with the backward Euler,
implicit Euler approximations.
So I replaced the
time derivative
with the difference between
the state at point tk
and the state of
point tk minus 1
divided by the difference
between tk and tk minus 1.
The other state variables
are evaluated at tk.
So x at tk.
And I evaluate time at tk.
And I try to satisfy
this equation
and use it to determine x of tk.
So I solve this system
of nonlinear equations
for x at tk.
And then I go to the next
point in time, tk plus 1.
And I solve the same equation,
but replacing tk with tk plus 1
and tk minus 1 with tk.
So at each iteration I solve a
system of nonlinear equations.
No more painful than
doing the forward Euler
approximation I
showed you before.
So that's good.
But still a lot of work.
We might wonder
how do we control
the error in these
sorts of approximations.
And that's what we're
going to talk about next.
So here's the equivalent
time marching formula
applied to a semi-explicit DAE.
So I've got to
satisfy the equation
0 is equal to the derivative
of x with respect to time,
which I approximate with the
backward Euler approximation,
minus f evaluated at tk.
And the equation g of x at
tk, y at tk for this x of tk.
And actually y of tk as well.
I'm sorry, I left that
off. y of tk as well.
Got to solve for
the differential
and the algebraic
states simultaneously.
And I use a backwards
difference formula
to try to do this
in a stable way.
One way to think about in
particular these sorts of DAEs
is as exceptionally stiff
ordinary differential
equations.
Did you guys discuss stiffness?
So imagine if I replace
the 0 with, say, dy dt.
And I introduced a constant
on the right-hand side,
a multiplicative constant,
say, 1 over lambda here.
Let's say lambda, actually.
Say I introduce a
multiplicative constant lambda
on the right-hand side here.
So as lambda becomes
very large, the system
becomes increasingly stiff.
The dynamics of
this equation take
place over very, very
short time scales.
So short in fact,
that eventually,
if I let lambda
diverge to infinity,
I've just got to satisfy
this algebraic equation
at each point in time.
So these are exceptionally
stiff equations.
And the methods for
solving these equations
share a lot in common with
stiff ODE-IVP solvers.
So I've got a couple
of minutes left.
I'm going to work
through some examples.
So consider the stirred
tank example one.
dc 2 dt.
It's related to q over
v, flow rate over volume.
The difference in
the concentrations
coming in and out of the tank.
And c1 is equal to this
input signal gamma.
Maybe that's a measurement
and I'm trying to predict c2.
So can you apply the backward
Euler method to these equations
to determine c1 and c2?
What would one step of the
backward Euler method look
like, say, going from time 0
to time delta t, or time t to t
plus delta t, or tk to
tk plus 1, however you
want to write it?
So do you get
something like this?
So this equation is easy.
c1 to tk is gamma of tk.
I got a substitute up here.
c2 of tk minus c2 of tk
minus 1 over delta t.
T Just tk minus tk minus 1.
And then solve for c2 of dk.
And you get a formula like this.
This formula was based
on an approximation
for the derivative,
which had a leading order
error that was proportional
to tk minus tk minus 1.
When I go through and I solve
for c2 of tk, the leading order
error in c2, the
local truncation error
is going to be order tk
minus tk minus 1 squared.
So as I shrink the spacing
between each of my two time
points, the local
accuracy, the error
induced in one advance of
this time stepping algorithm
is going to scale like
the step size squared.
So I have the error--
I have the spacing.
The error will go down
by a factor of four.
I reduce the spacing by
an order of magnitude.
The error will go down by
two orders of magnitude.
This is a really desirable sort
of error control and a method.
And we can do better.
You've seen us do better
with other methods.
Let's look at this equation now.
This is stirred
tank example two.
I just replace c1 with c2.
You don't have to
write this one down.
I'll just show it to you.
The notes are online so
you're not missing anything.
All these things will pop
up in the notes online.
So c2 at tk is equal
to gamma of tk.
I got to come up to
my first equation now
and I have to substitute
an approximation
for the derivative.
It's this, the backwards
difference formula.
So if find c1 of tk is
c2 of tk plus v over q.
c2 of tk minus c2 of tk minus
1 divided by the time step.
Remember, this approximation
for the derivative
has a leading order error that
goes like tk minus tk minus 1.
So my approximation for c1,
the local approximation for c1,
is not second order accurate.
It's only first order accurate.
I applied the same approximation
method to both equations.
One equation I got something
that was second order accurate.
The next equation
I got something
that was first order accurate.
They look almost identical.
It might be hard to
see from the start
why it should work out that way.
That's how it works out.
Let's do one more example.
Here's a system of DAEs.
c2 dot is equal to c1.
c3 dot is equal to c2.
And 0 is equal to
c3 minus gamma.
So gamma, again, is
some measurement.
We solve this equation
to determine c3.
We substitute c3 up
here to determine c2.
We substitute c2 up
here to determine c1.
But we want to find the solution
with the backward Euler method.
And the solution there is going
to be c3 of tk is gamma of tk.
c2 is related to the
derivative of c3.
So I use my backwards
difference formula
for the derivative of c3.
c1 is related to the
derivative of c2.
So I use my backward
difference formula for c2.
But how accurate are each
of these approximations?
So here I have to determine
c2 from an approximation
for the derivative of c3.
We know this backwards
difference approximation
has a leading order
error proportional
to delta t, the time step.
Now I got to approximate c1 with
the finite difference backwards
difference approximation in c2.
We know this should incur an
error proportional to the time
step delta t, except I
don't know c2 at tk exactly.
Actually, c2 tk, the
exact value of c2 at tk
is this plus something
proportional to the time step.
Which means the
exact value of c1
is this plus something
that's order one because I
carry over the error
from my solution
to the previous equation.
And I divide it
by the time step.
So I went from having
something-- well, let's see.
The first equation
had order delta t
squared local truncation error.
As I shrink the
spacing, my solution
gets more and more
locally accurate.
And it seems to do it in
a fairly robust fashion.
The next system of
equations we solved
had a local truncation error
proportional to delta t.
Again, I can shrink
delta t and I
can make my solution
more and more accurate.
That seems like what you want
in a numerical algorithm.
This one, there's no hope.
Change delta t, who knows
what you're going to get?
And this looks fairly innocuous.
You just look at it
and you say, well, OK.
Let's solve it and
see what happens.
Well actually, you can't
solve this problem accurately
with the backward Euler method.
There's something
fundamentally different
about this problem
from the previous one.
There's something fundamentally
different about stirred
tank example two from
stirred tank example one.
Right you might have
already perceived that.
You can see what's
going on here.
c3 is equal to gamma.
That's the exact solution.
c2 is equal to gamma dot.
And c1 is equal
to two derivatives
of gamma, the exact
solution to this equation.
So c1 is incredibly sensitive
to changes in gamma.
And that's peculiar.
And it has important
numerical consequences.
So I'm going to show you, our
next lecture on Wednesday,
how to formalize
an understanding
of the differences
between these problems.
And we'll talk about some
more subtleties associated
with differential
algebraic equations.
You guys can pick
up your quizzes.
We should do it
outside rather than
inside because the next
class has to start.